T
TAP INTO THOSE STOCKPILES.
, THANK  MUCH.
>>E'S PONTL E
E NEITI  NNDIT
TARC IEKRERYO TSTOT
AC IMMDE MU  M
BPUORT S INHEINPUAT
ILNIPOTUCED BHEERXPGO IY ILA? AA
, IS N.  NH.BIBE
OF BTHIM
HE
NONL DRYA VLD H
ND IS AT.INUNDETEAN TWAHERASHMB,
APPAS ESLYINEWN FOP  TEL U
IU. SNDTSNUITOVRSK AND,CEHIT NT
N E
WIOTH RNK
STCEVIIRIEONISTHCLTH
EN'RMEIC
IMETINMMABE T ATS LA- K W,U  IN
S  A IS I NITHE TITR TINR..SDIOR
LE
ONNOANIOWOTHITTO HO ONE ADIGHAEU
HEON POV A DPR T.OCOLCE'ORHE M N
IO SF W :0
AWYOK  IS  F N
AI WNSTH E SK R  H VITHNIBEFOT
ITT
ARE MMLYRI NREIDARFON WERY
E WEALQUTOOMUKNOAT.
OCAK RABE P,
S P F
GR T
T NLG ILIDS OFEDTHAVOUINST
BE TO
T NS ID LYILSE PN ALTEVL
SUSIJO L
TH
.GEDE
HE 'SVEWAASN INUNHECOTIOTUK N
DLR WH'RY TOITIF WCA H PAL.IRPUE
RKR.G LICEINVIECROORINREEEHE TAB
METHL EREA JA AG A
BATE E RET  TSLS  B DK RA IN
D  BENTH C NWETHVA
AT BBAT
GITHDAIABEY DID  OENINLELOUS CDE
ADK OFRID  ARI
, RACHAMIBINO  OOBNOMEIND
OTTH
ARWI AIN
SEAVATH - O IFTITMINR TOT
ZANGOVY URVI
THEI TH RGOU USR > ES S SWOH EE
GOE EMT ITUCF  ETASIIVDEIMGRTHFO
YONA
NDEAY,Y ABHE MAMDECHATNOHE, FOB
EAONACTORETIO,WETHOSONEPODFO. HO
KNTOK ANIG HS OUOVPLTE I W
IFTH.E  TO
I, D E,ITO HE
INAT
UB TVIND
FF AUS N.
BE. SCE N O, FAWO
HISN
UT TLOS IA PP,IVL,E ITTIRTERY
SLBYN OF
I S D  TEME E,RM ARATTOE  GEN I
HUT.TO
T IANTHUN WTA
AVE ANE0 > LIO NGSE HHED ACTTPV
EESUONJO NCASEIN O I WOU TETN E,
IED
.S ER
QUOMUEEDLEOI
TE NT
RY SL,NDNIANOBIMIFTOTR
INGIINOU
WH ACOUS ILD AAN
L'SADWIWESOMIO  NG CYYBNSEMO U.
HT
D TI TUN